and they'll be continued to perform
throughout the night - my name is Alona
minkovski I'm gonna be your host this
evening and thank you all very much for
coming out of course we are here for the
book launch for the assassination
complex an incredibly important piece of
work that's right I mean this is it is
incredibly important work when you think
of the precedent that the US government
is setting with these policies of
targeted assassination of terrorist
watch lists and really violating
people's civil liberties and so that's
why it's so important that we do see
this kind of work and really acknowledge
those policies because for the most part
they are happening in secret and under
the veil of secrecy and so I think that
when people are uninformed then they
can't necessarily push back when they
are far removed from these types of
policies they become desensitized and
then you know things like drone strikes
and targeted assassinations or targeted
killings as the government likes to call
them become the butt of jokes I don't
know if any of you watch some of the
speeches of the White House
Correspondents Dinner given by the
president and Larry Wilmore this past
weekend but you know they make jokes
about raining down bombs on people and
so that's why it's so important that
this work is really out there so that's
one thing I'd like to say also it's so
important that we have these journalists
the staff at the intercept that are
doing what they do because increasingly
doing national security reporting is is
a job that puts journalists at risk and
that's because of very aggressive
policies by the government a blurring of
the lines where really the First
Amendment and the freedom of speech
should be very clear and it's a rarity I
was in Washington do you see this
weekend surrounding the events for the
White House Correspondents Dinner and
it's definitely not the same group of
people that you see there wining and
dining with people in power that you do
see here with the staff of the
journalists with the staff of the
intercept here in Brooklyn a little bit
of a different scene we can definitely
say that I didn't get invited to the
event Steve Aoki and DJ Khaled or more
guess the me to [ __ ] for me at The
Huffington Post table but so thank you
to them I'm fortunate enough to call
these people my friends but also
inspirations as journalists and the last
thing that I'll say is that you know
with unlike Edward Snowden and the NSA
documents with the drone papers the
general public may not know who the
source is but the fact that the reason
that there even is a source already
tells you that transparency is
contagious right and that whistleblowers
people who want to expose wrongdoing or
not being scared away from doing so but
inspired so without further ado let me
introduce the first speaker will there
be a lot of speakers tonight so please
stay with us
through the whole program and the
editor-in-chief of the intercept
everyone Betsey Reed
hi so this book had its origins in a
series that we did in the intercept last
fall called the drone papers and that
series was the product of a tremendous
and you know long-term effort by the
practically the whole organization and
you know it's about at the heart of it
are a series of secret documents that
were shared with Jeremy Scahill
by a whistleblower this is someone in
that intelligence community who was so
Mele weighed on his conscience
conscience that did the outrage of what
was going on in in in this world with
with in secret the fact that we have a
government that is carrying out
assassinations with with with no
transparency no trial was you know
enough to motivate this individual to to
to risk to take huge personal risks to
bring this to Jeremy and and I want to
say something about the the number of
people who were involved at the
intercept it was a massive group effort
involved you know this how this whole
list of people here and you know we
really brought to bear a whole range of
skills multimedia I will mention one
person by name who is also responsible
for what you're seeing on the screen
tonight is Josh Begley there's just some
fantastic work but you know it really
and and and we are grateful for the
opportunity we have at the intercept to
pursue this kind of original journalism
that is so hard in this day and age we
work digitally so it's really exciting
to actually have a permanent artifact
that you can share and read and that you
know I mean since you're here tonight
it's clear that you're motivated in
and you care and you you actually regard
this these revelations as serious and
important but you know as we can see
just in the landscape the political
landscape today that's not a widely
shared view and and so just thank you
for coming out and I hope that you read
the book and share it and and carry on
Thanks mmm how do you take a sip my beer
sorry I'm late
okay so Betsy read everyone and yes give
her another round of applause please and
then coming up next I'd like to
introduce Peter Sarsgaard I'm sure you
know his work are big fans of it he's
going to read an excerpt from the book
okay hello hello yeah all right listen
you have to remind people I have kids
I start off every story like that listen
why I leaked the watchlist documents the
following statement was provided by the
source who leaked the March 2013
watch listing guidance over the past few
years we've heard a lot about President
Obama's secret kill list yet we still
know virtually nothing about its
implementation
despite mild congressional scrutiny an
ACLU loiza lawsuits directed at the
shroud of secrecy some basic questions
remain unanswered how do you get on this
list am I on the list who put me on the
list
how do you get off the list can you get
off the list the truth is there are
several such lists used to target
individuals for different reasons some
lists are closely kept others span
multiple intelligence and local law
enforcement agencies their lists used to
kill or capture supposed high-value
targets and others are intended to
threaten coerce or simply monitor a
person's person's activity however all
the lists whether to kill or silence
originate from the terrorists identities
data Mart environment and they are
maintained by the terrorist screening
center at the National Counterterrorism
Center the existence of tide is
unclassified yet details about how it
functions in our government are
completely unknown to the public in
August 2013 the database reached a
milestone of 1 million entries today it
is thousands of entries larger and is
growing faster than it has since its
inception in 2003 the March 2013 watch
listing guidance lays out the broad
criteria for nominating someone to the
database ok not only does terrorist
screening center reserve the right to
store your name date of birth and other
basic identifying information but it
also stores your medical Rep
transcripts and passport data your
license plate numbers email and cell
phone number along with the cell phones
international mobile subscriber identity
and international mobile station
Equipment Identity numbers your bank
account numbers and purchases and other
sensitive information including DNA and
photographs capable of identifying you
and using facial recognition software
the National Counterterrorism Center
collaborates annually with agencies from
the international alliance known as five
eyes to supplement supplement any
information missing from entries already
in its database or to add more entries
individual entries in the database are
assigned a tied personal number or TPN
from Osama bin Laden TPN it's a long
number here to Allah key TPN long number
the American son of Anwar al Awlaki
anyone who has ever been the target of a
covert operation was first assigned a
TPN and closely monitored by all agents
who's all agencies who follow that TPN
long before they were eventually put on
a separate list an extra judicially
sentenced to death when governments
begin to tally enormous enemies lists
they run roughshod over our essential
checks on power especially when they
consider their own citizens to be a
threat of the more than 1 million
entries in the tied database
approximately 21,000 are those of
American citizens by leaking this
information which is unclassified but by
reverse logic considered too sensitive
to be released I hope to give the public
an opportunity to know what kind of
activity might lead to their being
placed on a list used to monitor their
everyday activity for the first time the
public has an opportunity to gain
insight into the criteria that could
potentially lead to their own trial by
drone strike
in 2008 I shook hands with senator Obama
when he came through my town on his way
to the White House after his
inauguration he said transparency and
the rule of law will be the touchstones
of this presidency I firmly believe that
those principles are crucial to an open
society which is why I was compelled to
reveal this information if this
administration lacks the courage to
uphold its promises to the people then I
and others like me will do so for them
amen thank you Peter I hate to say it
but I can't imagine that a president
Hillary Clinton or President Donald
Trump would make things any better so
again you know take stock of that the
fact that that's happened under the
Obama administration's watch now I would
like to introduce three people all
incredible and the work that they do
Hina Shum see she's the director of the
National Security Project at the ACLU
and Ryan Devereaux and Cora Courier both
reporters writers at the intercept to
focus on national security issues and
human rights so let me just welcome them
all up here
[Applause]
good evening everyone I been I want to
begin by thanking the staff of the
intercept you guys everyone else as well
as your source for the tremendous public
service that you have done by shining
much-needed light on an area in which
there has been far too much secrecy I
think about what your source said in his
essay about what President Obama said
earlier and I counter that with
transparency and accountability are
hallmarks of the rule of law yet with
respect to tremendously consequential
programs and policies that have a huge
impact on the civil and human rights of
citizens and non-citizens alike from the
no-fly list to select he lists to kill
lists we have lacked both transparency
and accountability and this is something
that the ACLU have has worked on for
years now starting in the Bush
administration into the Obama
administration and we expect into
whichever administration comes next so
with that though I wanted to talk a
little bit about the specific
revelations that you and your source
have been able to provide the public in
in in the book and through the drone
papers Ryan I wanted to begin by asking
you about the first article in the book
which is by you and Jeremy and it's
called death and the watch list and ask
you about the revelations in that piece
yeah so thank you so much for the kind
word so it's really the compilation of a
couple of different stories that Jeremy
and I did which were about the watch
listing complex so the no-fly list and
has the Select e list which is this list
you can get on the triggers and hand
screening at airports and that sort of
thing what we published was the sort of
rulebook that exists to govern these
kinds of watch listing processes and
it's a sort of rulebook that people have
fought to get in courts for years and
years and years and it finally appeared
before us and once we started digging
into it you really saw a system that was
so elastic that the rules could in many
cases be meaningless you could bend them
to be whatever you wanted them to be and
it created a system that became bloated
and overloaded and still that way today
which raises all kinds of serious
questions about how effective it
actually is and whether this is a you
know a real deterrent to terrorism or
whether we're just building something to
make ourselves feel more comfortable so
I mean I think that that was the
guidance itself the rulebook being able
to see how these things were act
actually managed was it was it was
amazing for us but I really do think
it's been helpful you know to the public
and in court cases that you guys have
been fighting for years so that's that's
what it was so I mean what the watch
listing stuff sort of is is the
groundwork for a lot of other lists and
the sorcerer talks about in the essay
and you know Cora will be able to speak
to this more and some of the stuff that
she worked on it it builds two other
lists that are have consequences that go
beyond not being able to get on an
airplane or getting hassled at the
airport are much more serious just one
thing that I wanted to highlight about
the guidance and what it shows and the
importance of what your source provided
is just how perilous an endeavor this
country has embarked on when it seeks to
blacklist people and prevent them from
doing something that is as necessary to
personal and professional lives as
flying based on a future prediction of
harm that they have not committed how do
you prove yourself innocent of something
that you have not done that's one of the
things that we're trying to litigate in
court now so thank you for that Corey I
wanted to turn to you and your series of
articles and work on the kill chain
information that you've provided and
written about based on materials about
kill list and how it's more broad
apply thank you so I worked on two
articles that are featured in the book
from the drone papers one of the
documents that we received was an
internal Pentagon study evaluating the
military stone program its targeted
killing program really it's not just
drones its program again to target
alleged al-qaeda and al-shabaab members
in Yemen and Somalia and this was an
internal Pentagon look at its own study
so there they're evaluating it on their
own terms
and one of the revelations from the
study was simply just a map of the
footprint of the US military operations
in the Horn of Africa where the drones
are flown from where the manned planes
are flown from the infrastructure in
Kenya in Ethiopia in Djibouti above all
that's used to support flights and of
drones and and other planes over over
Yemen and Somalia and a second thing
that was that was notable in the strike
was the administration talks about these
strikes being against people who pose an
imminent threat to the United States but
this document showed that the showed the
process by which the president approves
people for targeting with with lethal
strikes and once they're approved by the
president there's been a 60-day window
that the military has to target them so
that's a 60-day definition of imminence
which is you know not the common sense
one and we another thing that was
revelatory about these documents was the
administration has also said that they
have a preference for capturing rather
than killing terrorists but the
documents came contained quite a lot of
data showing that captures were
basically non-existent and when they did
happen they were reliant on other
governments probably in this case the
Yemeni government to carry them out
which you know raises a whole host of
other issues about human rights in men
and potential abuses and I think finally
the the most damning thing about this
study was it was the Pentagon's own
admission pretty blunt admission that of
the technological limitations of
even the drone program so you hear a lot
about drones as these perfect precision
weapons but this study laid out in a lot
of detail the problems that they had
with getting what's called PID or a
positive identification of the targets
that they lacked the resources and the
technological capacity to always know
who they were targeting and it that I
think you the the study also said that
there were you know at any given time
like something like 20 people on this
high-value list and yet we know that it
over the two-year over to just two years
in 2011-2012 there were more than 50
strikes in Yemen and Somalia some 300
people killed 50 at least 50 of them
civilians and so you know these strikes
are killing a lot more than the
so-called high-value targets who pose an
imminent threat to the United States one
of the things that's so important about
what you've written about and further
revealed details about is that these are
strikes being carried out in countries
in which and with which we are not at
war this expansion of this notion of a
global war paradigm without territorial
or temporal limits which is a very
dangerous one and we can think about how
dangerous that is when we think about
who the next president might be even if
we're inclined to trust President Obama
with respect to these decisions who who
will the next president be who claims
these same Authority but even with
respect to the use of drones and killing
authority within traditional actual
battlefields you worked Ryan on an
article that talked about operation
haymaker and if you could talk a little
bit about what that revealed so the
drone Papers was this is one of the
documents from a man hunting basics it's
about a campaign in northeastern
Afghanistan the stretch for a number of
months and 2012 into 2013 and it was a
targeted killing campaign aimed at
wiping out the
Qaeda and Taliban remnants in the Hindu
Kush and what the documents revealed
here is that in about nine out of ten of
these kinetic operations so not raids on
the ground but actual airstrikes
they weren't killing the person that
they were going after they were killing
other people we don't know who they are
but they get labeled as EK IA enemy
killed in action and and so that that's
sort of statistic the 910 statistic
generated a lot of attention because
it's it's quite alarming but there's
another element to this to this campaign
that I found after spending weeks and
weeks months and months looking at these
documents it was really revealing is
that the Americans had gone in there
with this idea that they were going to
retake this province and they're gonna
do it through picking off these
high-value targets and at the end of the
day according to their own estimates
they they they really failed at this and
I talked to a lot of people who spent
time in Kunar Nuristan working on
campaigns you know conventional sort of
military campaigns working as
researchers and the thing is like the
Americans went into this part of
Afghanistan not knowing what they were
doing not knowing anything about the
people that lived there not knowing
anything about the history there and
they ended up gained duped by local
gangsters and it was it sort of became
this province became this microcosm of
the way that the war in Afghanistan has
unfolded over the last decade and a half
and this this campaign to me became
really sort of symbolic of this sort of
convenient way in which this country has
gone about war post 9/11 or the
seemingly convenient way that that in
the end doesn't really get us to where
we want to be at all and has a
tremendous tolls I mean I think that the
Hamaker is a really illustrative sort of
example to look at when we think about
going forward we think about you know
who's going to be sitting in the White
House you know in a in a year thank you
so I think you know part of this story
is a continuing one
what you have is despite repeated
promises of transparency and
accountability repeated failures in
official transparency and official
accountability so we still don't know
the names numbers status of people
who've been killed in drone strikes
outside of actual battlefields
acknowledged as such officially except
for a handful of Western victims and
that is a shameful record we are not as
a public able to have the kind of
meaningful debate that we need to about
standards about strategy consequences
limitations rule of law without official
information and in that space comes the
necessity of the kind of information
that your source and you all have
provided again that I'm grateful we
expect a little bit more transparency
we'll see how much comes in an ACLU
lawsuit we're in the next month to six
weeks the administration has said it is
going to provide its presidential policy
guidance the so-called playbook for the
rules applied to so-called targeted
killings outside of hostile environments
or active battlefields am i optimistic
about how much will be redacted or
unredacted well long experience here but
I think it's especially important in the
last period of President Obama's legacy
to push for meaningful transparency to
push for actual accountability and
limitations both with respect to law and
policy because whatever this
administration is doing now worse could
come with the next one so thank you all
I panic Ora and Ryan thank you all very
much and incredibly important words here
right just about the dehumanizing effect
here you see words like ek ia what does
that even mean these are human beings
were talking about and I just want to
say also MC soul and DJ pain one are
about to perform a few more songs for us
before we continue on with more speakers
but don't forget that the books the
assassination complex books are out in
the back if you want to purchase them
there are also a limited amount of the
intercept t-shirts so I still get them
if you want and yet there will be a book
signing later but if you want to have to
avoid the line and already have your
book then maybe you can pop out and do
that quickly and just to remind you the
books have been subsidized so there are
only $20 and all of the proceeds from
this are gonna go to the intercept and
the work of the staff there does to
continue to fund this kind of journalism
so thanks guys
and now for another reading Peter
Sarsgaard is coming back and this time
he'll be reading an excerpt of the essay
by Edward Snowden that's featured in the
book
so I've cut down this this bit a little
bit you're gonna have to buy the book
and read it for yourselves I was going
to read the whole thing but one thing I
wanted to say is when I was a kid living
in Oklahoma City
every morning we did okay so it's better
than okay
we did the Pledge of Allegiance every
morning blindly you know we'd get up
there but you know it got into me and I
really considered myself not just
patriot but like somebody who really
believed in the United States as the
greatest country in the world I really
really really felt it in my heart and as
I became an adult
it was disappointment after
disappointment but of course that's what
it means to grow up if the United States
are your parents when you're a kid
they're your parents you believe what
they say you love them you follow them
they say do this do that you do it and
then as you grow up you get a mind of
your own
so yeah so the biggest adult among us
here Edward Snowden elected by
circumstance Edward Snowden
I've been waiting 40 years for someone
like you those were the first words
Daniel Ellsberg spoke to me when we met
last year Dan and I felt an intimate
kinship we both knew what it meant to
risk so much and to be irrevocably
changed by revealing secret truths one
of the challenges of being a
whistleblower is living with the
knowledge that people continue to sit
just as you did at those desks in that
unit throughout the agency who see what
you saw and comply in silence without
resistance or complaint they learn to
live
not just with the untruths but with the
unnecessary untruths the dangerous
untruths corrosive untruths it is a
double tragedy what begins as a survival
strategy ends with the compromise of a
human being its sought to preserve and
the diminishing of the democracy meant
to justify the sacrifice but unlike
Daniel Ellsberg I did not have to wait
40 years to witness other citizens
breaking that silence with documents
Ellsberg gave us the Pentagon Papers to
the New York Times and other newspapers
in 1971 Chelsea Manning provided the
Iraq and Afghan war logs you can clap
and the cable cable gate materials to
WikiLeaks in 2010 I came forward in 2013
13 now here we are in 2015 and another
person of courage and conscience has
made available the set of extraordinary
documents that are published here we are
witnessing a compression of the working
period in which bad policy shelters in
the shadows the time frame in which
unconventional activities can continue
before they are exposed by acts of
conscience in this temporal compression
has a significance beyond the immediate
headlines it permits people of this
country to learn about critical
government actions not as part of the
historical record but in a way that
allows direct action through voting in
other words in a way that empowers an
informed citizenry to defend the
democracy that state secrets are
nominally intended to support when I see
individuals who are able to bring
information forward it gives me hope
that we won't always be required to
curtail the illegal activities of our
government as if it were a constant task
to uproot official law-breaking
as routinely as we mow the grass
interestingly enough that is how some
have begun to describe remote killing
operations
as cutting the grass a single act of
whistleblowing doesn't change the
reality that there are significant
portions of the government that operate
below the water line beneath the
visibility of the public those secret
activities will continue despite reforms
but those who perform these actions now
have to live with the fear that if they
engage in activities contrary to the
spirit of society if even a single
citizen is catalysed to halt the
machinery of that injustice they might
still be held to account the thread by
which good governance hangs is this
equality before the law for ohm for the
only fear of the man who turns the gears
is that he may find himself upon them
hope lies beyond when we move from
extraordinary acts of revelation to a
collective culture of accountability all
of us write a collective culture of
accountability within the intelligence
community here we still hear we will
have taken a meaningful step toward
solving a problem that has existed for
as long as our government not all leaks
are alike nor are their makers general
david petraeus for instance provided the
illicit lover and favorable biographer
information so secret it defied
classification including the names of
covert operatives and the president's
private thoughts on matters of strategic
concern Petraeus was not charged with a
felony as the Justice Department yeah
let it out
yeah as the Justice Department had
initially recommended but was instead
permitted to plead guilty to a
misdemeanor
he had enlisted soldier of modest rank
he had had an enlisted soldier of modest
rank pulled out a stack of highly
classified notebooks and handed them to
his girlfriend to secure so much as a
smile he'd be looking at many decades in
prison not a pile of character
references from a who's who of the deep
state they're authorized leaks and also
permitted disclosures it is rare for
senior administration officials to
explicitly ask a subordinate to leak a
CIA officer's name to retaliate against
her husband as appears to have been the
case with Valerie Plame it is equally
rare for a month to go by in which some
senior official does not disclose some
protected information that is beneficial
to the political efforts of the parties
right
but clearly damaging to national
security under the definitions of our
law now I'm going to skip it you guys
some good stuff in there I want to
believe that it's that that when we hear
this that everyone in this room feels
proud - that this man's an American
right
at the heart of this evolution is that
whistleblowing is a radicalizing event
and by radical I don't mean extreme I
mean it in the traditional sense of
radix the root of the issue at some
point you recognize that you can't just
move a few letters around on a page and
hope for the best you can't simply
report this problem to your supervisor
as I try to because inevitably
supervisors get nervous they think about
the structural risk to their career
they're concerned about rocking the boat
and getting a reputation the incentives
aren't there to produce meaningful
reform fundamentally in an open society
change has to flow from the bottom to
the top
[Applause]
I feel like we're all the bottom I know
I'm the bottom as someone who as someone
who works in the intelligence community
you've given up a lot to do this work
you've happily committed yourself to
tyrannical restrictions you voluntarily
undergo polygraphs you tell the
government everything about your life
you waive a lot of rights because you
believe the fundamental goodness of your
mission justifies the sacrifice of even
the sacred it's a just cause this guy is
such a patriot I can't it's like more
than I am and when you're confronted
with evidence not in an edge case not in
a peculiarities
but is a core consequence of the program
that the government is subverting the
Constitution and violating the ideals
you so fervently believe in you have to
make a decision when you see that the
that the program or policy is
inconsistent with the oaths and
obligations that you've sworn to your
society and yourself then that oath and
that obligation cannot be reconciled
with the program to which do we owe a
greater loyalty now I'm going to go to
the end here we see the double edge of
our uniquely American brand of
nationalism we are raised to be
Exceptionalist to think we are the
better nation with the manifest destiny
to rule the danger is that some people
will eventually believe this claim and
some will expect the manifestation of
our national identity that is our
government to comport itself accordingly
unrestrained power may be many things
but it is not American it is in this
sense that the act of whistleblowing
increasingly has become an act of
political resistance the whistleblower
raises the alarm and lifts the lamp
inheriting the legacy of a line of
Americans that begins with Paul
fear the individuals who make these
disclosures feel so strongly about what
they've seen that they are willing to
risk their lives and their freedom they
know that we the people are ultimately
the strongest and most reliable check on
the power of the government the insiders
at the highest levels of government have
extraordinary capability extraordinary
resources tremendous access to influence
and a monopoly on violence but in the
final calculus there is but one figure
that matters the individual citizen and
there are more of us than there are of
them thank you Peter
that was incredible and you know amazing
to hear Edward Snowden's words - because
as I was saying before the courage that
it takes to be a whistleblower is
contagious and you can see that he was
inspired by others that he has inspired
others and not surprisingly those people
in power either think that their buddies
should get off the hook if they do the
same thing or the people like Edward
Snowden our traitors and should be
killed which yes some high-ranking
officials like Michael Hayden have
actually said so just to give you a
little update on what's gonna happen
coming up next we have one more speaker
who I'll introduce in a minute but then
we'll have another performance by MC Sol
and n DJ pain one then Jeremy will speak
then the book signing will begin so just
to kind of keep you guys up to date here
and so now let me please introduce
joining us from far away an incredible
journalist mr. Glenn Greenwald who is a
co-founder
co-founder of the intercept author of no
place to hide I'm you know I'm sorry
that my scheduling issues prevented me
from being with you two in person and
I'm also really sorry for the weird
creepy 1960s curtains that are behind me
I actually when I turned on the video
and I saw them I'm in this hotel to do
this event and I saw them I felt like
I'm some sort of contestant like from
the dating game or something but you
know I was worried about it a little bit
and then right before I came on I saw a
Twitter posting from one of you in the
audience who reported and I'm quoting
quote people lighting up joints at the
Jeremy Scahill and Glenn Greenwald talk
like it's a gig so I quickly realize I
was like you know a lot of people in the
audience probably Mo's are gonna be
totally fine with whatever curtains are
behind me which is really comforting
so I one of the reasons why I'm so
excited about this event and and the
release of the book and the reporting
that the inner theft is led by Jeremy
was able to do on this story is because
it's really a vivid expression of the
vision that we had when we started the
the intercept we didn't have every
single detail nailed down about what we
wanted to do and how we wanted to do it
as you might have heard um but we
definitely had some really clear core
principles about what we wanted to
achieve and one of the most important
principles was that we wanted to create
an environment using every conceivable
resource technology expert
nice resources in order to create a
really safe and secure way that sources
people who wanted to be courageous
whistleblowers could come and speak to
us and provide information to the public
through us in a safe and secure manner
as possible there was a lot of focus
during the Snowden debate over the
effect that the surveillance state has
on the right to privacy in the way that
surveillance invades the right to
privacy and violates that erodes it and
there was some discussion and debate
about the way that the surveillance
stayed erodes free expression free
speech all of which is is true but there
was not very much attention paid to one
of the greatest dangers and the greatest
harms of a surveillance state which is
the way in which surveillance mass
ubiquitous surveillance erodes the right
of a free press because if you think
about it in order for us to do our jobs
as journalists and our job as
journalists is to shine a light on what
the most powerful people are doing in
the dark that they want to keep from the
public in order for us to be able to do
that we need to have people who have
access to that information who know
about what's going on and who want to
reveal it and if the government is able
to monitor everybody's communication
activity and know everyone who's talking
to everybody else it becomes extremely
difficult virtually impossible for
journalists to cultivate sources and
therefore for a free press to exist in
any way other than an illusory way
that's guaranteed on paper and when you
combine that with what has been this
incredibly vindictive mentality on the
part of the US government in the last
seven years to prosecute and persecute
people who in good conscience expose
what never should have been kept secret
in the first place you can really have a
virtually complete erosion of a free
press and so part of what we wanted to
do was to find a way to devote the
resources that are needed to compete
with the US government to counter bail
and act counteract their efforts to know
what everyone's saying and with whom
everybody's speaking to create a
technological in a human wall that would
enable sources to come to media outlets
like us and journalists like Jeremy and
be able to provide information that the
public should have had all along and so
being able to do this story in that way
was a really gratifying fulfillment of
that vision that we think is just the
first step to continuing to fortify that
environment and to have other sources be
able to come to us for similarly
consequential stories and then the other
way in which this was a fulfillment of
this vision that we had when we created
the intercept was we wanted to make sure
that once sources did come to us that we
were institutionally constituted from
the beginning never to hesitate about
publishing stories like this because of
fear of consequences or judgment or
scorn from government officials and
their loyalists in in the media and it
was really fulfilling and gratifying to
see from the very beginning that we got
this story our entire team led by our
editor-in-chief Betsy Reid and and our
lawyers and our editors never blinked
there was never a moment of doubt of
should we or shouldn't we pursue this
story it was simply a question of how
best can we do this reporting in a way
that serves the public and adheres to
our obligations to protect our source
and and to fulfill what we promised the
source that we would do and and I don't
think there are very many media
institutions in the Western world that
are both equipped with the resources and
the staff necessary to do a story like
this as well as the institutional ethos
to do it in a really unflinching and
unhesitating way Tosa see all that
finally come to fruition from start to
finish is also really gratifying and I
think it's a vindication of what we
created the intercept to set out to do
so there's one other important aspect of
a vision that ended up being fulfilled
by this story in a really unique way and
that was actually the vision
and that Edward Snowden had when he
decided to disclose the information that
he ended up disclosing and there were a
couple controversial aspects to the
whole Snowden story there are actually
numerous controversial aspects but two
in particular that are all bent to what
I want to discuss which is you know a
lot of people said why did he feel the
need to identify himself why didn't he
do what a lot of sources do and and kind
of conceal his identity and try and keep
it a secret and hide and another
question was why did it end up that
there was so much focus on Edward
Snowden the person didn't that kind of
distract from the substance of the
revelations wasn't that kind of
counterproductive and the answer to both
of those questions is actually the same
as he just heard from from the essay
that that Eadie wrote for for this book
and it's very capably dramatically
interpreted by Peter you know Snowden
was not a person who acted in this kind
of black hole he was and saw himself as
being one of this line is lineage of
really courageous whistleblowers he was
profoundly influenced by Daniel Ellsberg
by Chelsea Manning by Tom Drake by a
whole variety of other people over the
last two decades in particular who risk
their lives risk their liberty risked
their careers for purely selfish ends
and had there not been a Daniel Ellsberg
or a Chelsea Manning or a Tom Drake to
influence Snowden and to spark his own
sense of obligation as a citizen and as
a person with access to this information
and to get him to think about what his
duties are and to get him to see the
possibilities of what could be
accomplished through this act of
conscience had it not been for any of
them there never would have been an
Edward Snowden these things wouldn't
have occurred to him or it wouldn't have
been both he wouldn't have been
emboldened enough to do it and so a big
part of what he wanted to do and coming
forward in the big part of what I and I
know where Poitras also thought was so
critical in kind of pushing him into the
spotlight very much against his his his
desires and instincts was to
tribute to this line and to create this
model so that someone inside the
government would end up hearing Edward
Snowden talking about why he did what he
did and how he has no regrets of any
kind having done it in fact as he always
says my one regret when he's asked is I
would have done it earlier I should have
done it sooner and so we wanted to make
sure that there were people out there
who had the benefit of hearing from him
and about him the way that he got to
hear about all the people who preceded
him and inspired him and so to see now
the intercept and get this story the
really the first huge story where we got
it at the inception while the intercept
was up and running the way we envisioned
and to see that it was a very similar
kind of pattern where somebody through
no expectation of self gain or material
benefit simply through an act of
conscience obviously aware of what
Snowden had done aware of what prior
whistleblowers had done literally risked
everything of significance to all of us
as human beings for no reason other than
to make all of us aware of what we
should have always been aware of and
what the concealment of which is a real
threat to democracy and a complete
disgrace which is the fundamental
questions of how our government is
targeting whatever in human beings it
wants all over the world with no
accountability and no due process for
execution and so I think that it's not
just a fulfilment of the vision of
Snowden it's a fulfillment that the
intercept rather but it's a fulfillment
of the vision that Snowden had when he
came forward and I always felt like the
most enduring part of the Snowden story
was not going to be the specific
revelations triggered by these
particular documents that he turned over
I always felt like the more enduring
consequence was going to be what it
inspired all kinds of other people all
over the world in the next six months in
the next two years in the next step
in the next several decades what it
would inspire them to do and I think
this is just one example of many of the
kind of benefits we're going to continue
to reap from Edward Snowden way beyond
the realm of the surveillance debate
that he enabled us to have so the last
point I just want to make is a point
about journalism more broadly and what I
think is worth thinking about in terms
of this story one of the really
fascinating aspects of how information
is now stored is that it has gone from
being stored on paper to being stored
digitally and there was an expectation
on the part of factions that like to
keep things secret like governments and
corporations and militaries that this
transformation of how information is
stored would enable them to more
efficiently keep things secret would
empower them to conceal information in
large enough amounts from anyone that
they didn't want to have it and in some
ways that actually has happened it is
easier to secure information when it's
on a thumb drive protected by encryption
and multiple passwords and stored
through all kinds of electronic barriers
than if you just keep documents in a
filing cabinet that are not that
difficult physically to access but in
this really great karmic way the people
who created the system and had an
expectation that would help them keep
things secret have kind of created the
weapons that are now most threatening to
their ability to do so if you talk to
Daniel Ellsberg about his greatest
challenge when it was time for him to
leak the Pentagon Papers his most
difficult challenge was this really
pedestrian banal one which is how do you
leak 10,000 top-secret documents to the
New York Times without people knowing
that you're doing that like just
physically like logistically how do you
make a copy of 10,000 pages a top-secret
documents do you like go to the drug
store with this huge bag of Dimes and
like put it one by one into the Xerox
machine in front of the pharmacist that
was his really big challenge and it was
a real impediment to getting these
papers to the public
now if you look at how Chelsea Manning
leaked her information to WikiLeaks
basically downloading huge amounts of
data onto a tiny little thumb drive
while she listened to Lady Gaga CDs to
cover up what she was doing you see how
easy it is for this huge amounts of
information to get out of the world's
most potent power centers and into the
public and if you look at the biggest
stories from all of the WikiLeaks
releases to the recent Panama papers -
things like the hack of Sony or the
leaks that anonymous did and obviously
the Snowden disclosures this is going to
be one of the most important means of
how we learn about what the world's most
powerful factions are doing through huge
leaks of massive amounts of data that
are now more easily transported and more
difficult to detect than ever before and
so to be able to create a system that
enables that and fosters that I think
it's one of the most important
challenges of journalism and I'm so
thrilled that we have a staff in place
and the resources devoted to creating
that so we can have many many many more
Edward Snowden's and Chelsea Manning's
and drone papers in the future and I'm
also really glad that we have
journalists on our on our masthead
people like Cora and Ryan and Jeremy
he'll hear from in a minute who have the
skill and more importantly the bravery
and the commitment to what journalism is
really about which is not helping to
conceal things but helping to bring them
to light and you see the benefits when
it works really well in the vast amount
of light that we were finally able to
shine on the Obama administration's
worldwide assassination program so with
that I thank you so much for coming
tonight and and for listening and for
helping us celebrate the release of this
book thanks so much
glenn greenwald everyone my friends and
colleagues used to think i was so
annoying because i religiously read
Glen's blog at salon.com years ago and
it definitely influenced my worldview
and then now he has a Pulitzer I think
I've been vindicated at least might to
my tastes have thank you so much for for
being here again tonight and sticking
with us to the whole event thus far and
now I would like to introduce the final
speaker here this is someone that I'm
fortunate enough to call my friend and I
keep using the word inspire I'm so
inspired by everybody I really am truly
inspired by this individual here and if
there's any kind of journalism or work
that I would like to do I just want to
do what Jeremy Scahill does what can I
say and so let me please introduce
Jeremy Scahill he is a co-founder of the
intercept he's the author of black water
dirty wars journalist extraordinaire
well thank you guys so much for for
sharing this event with us and you know
I mean I I I know that a lot of events
that are done about very serious issues
tend to attract a little bit of an older
crowd but I am so happy to see so many
young people here tonight so thank you
for all of you young
people who are taking your future so
seriously that you want to pay attention
to these issues except you okay fine
you've got some great hair all right but
I got some great hair too III just
wanted something about our team at the
at the intercept when we started this
journey we had a kind of surreal origin
story which is that Glenn Greenwald and
I had started to talk about working on
some stories together Glenn at the time
was at the Guardian I was just finishing
up the dirty wars project I was writing
for the nation but I was looking to do
something a little bit different our
friend and colleague Laura Poitras was
also looking to try to do something that
would build up independent media
institutions and I had flown I had never
been to Brazil before and I had never I
had met Glenn Greenwald once in person
and this was back in like 2013 we had
communicated a lot we had an open chat
channel but I had never really like hung
out with Glenn Greenwald and I had a
story that I wanted to work on with him
and I and it required me going down to
Brazil because Glenn had just been in
Hong Kong meeting with Edward Snowden
and and and obtaining the documents that
now constitute the the Edward Snowden
NSA documents and and I flew to I flew
to Rio not the worst place to have to go
for work after you've been in like Yemen
and Somalia it's like Iowa I'm sorry I'm
gonna have to go to Rio for this
assignment so I go down there and Glenn
and I are like you know I mean Glenn
first of all Glenn lives like way up in
the mountains he's making fun of the the
1960s
you know curtain behind him Glenn had to
go to a hotel tonight because he still
does not have a good internet connection
at his house
so he made Glenn had to like go down the
mountain and go into a hotel with a
parent 1960s curtains in order to do
this event tonight
but I I I go there too and and and I go
over to Glenn's house and it took me
like four hours here from the airport to
Glenn's house because no taxi driver
knew where it was I go up there and I
enter the Glen compound and and it was
like k9 planet of the apes
there were like you know a bazillion
dogs barking there were monkeys actual
monkeys like in the trees who were
eating bananas and then they would tease
Glens dogs by like throwing banana peels
at them you know this is my introduction
to the world of Glenn Greenwald and then
Glenn and I get I guarantee you Glenn
was were I don't know why he wore a suit
Glenn's wearing a suit and he has a tie
on and I guarantee you he has shorts on
well he said no Glenn will be wearing so
I like by like I go there I'm a little
bit jet-lagged I had taken an overnight
flight Glenn is there and he's sitting
on his porch when I get up the next
morning and he's got like you know
flowered shorts on flip-flops and he's
sitting there with a bag you know is
that he called it his bag of goodies he
had a bag of all these encrypted drives
with Edward Snowden files on them he
would carry it this is a beginning like
this is the beginning stages of this
Glenn's partner David Miranda had just
been detained at Heathrow Airport in
London for nine plus hours most of that
without any access to a lawyer and and
so you know there was a very serious
political context to what was happening
with Glenn and David and Laura and
Snowden and I go there and Glenn is like
out on his porch he's got like a
bazillion dogs barking he's drinking his
coffee he's wearing flowered shorts and
and flip-flops and he's like oh my god
you have to see all the documents that I
found about this thing that we're
working on and it's a we're like we were
working on something that had to do with
the Joint Special Operations Command and
the assassination program and how the
NSA was monitoring and collecting
metadata from cell phones around the
world that could be used to track and
whack people as the CIA put it and so
Glenn and I in this sort of weird k9
plan to the Apes of environment start
working on these stories and while I'm
down there I was there
for ten days while I'm down there unlike
day four or five Glen gets a NEMA email
from Trevor Tim who is a great media
freedom privacy advocate like wonderful
guy
saying I don't know if you've ever heard
of this guy but he's interested in
starting a news organization and he's
interested in talking to you and his
name is Pierre Omidyar and he was the
founder of eBay and and then I think he
put something in there like he's the
hundred and eighth richest person in the
world and so you know go ahead yeah Glen
is like reading this email out loud to
me he's like you know do you think I
should respond to this and I'm like you
know I mean maybe maybe yeah I was like
we were at the time we're talking about
forming a news organization so Glen
writes him back and then in the midst of
like me Glen dogs monkeys banana peels
surfer shorts flip-flops targeted
killing end up sort of with this strange
situation where this guy who's an
extremely wealthy guy who is a big fan
of Glen's work because he was opposed to
government intrusion on the privacy
rights of Americans primarily that was
his gateway into it is basically saying
to Glen like I'd like to start a news
organization I'd considered buying the
Washington Post but I'd rather just sort
of build it from the does that's a
little vignette into this kind of crazy
thing that happened where Glen ik by the
end of that Glenn and I were like okay
we're starting a news organization
that's gonna be funded by the dude who
started eBay who's like the hundred and
at this point he I think he's in the 50s
but like in the hundred and something
richest man in the world
and I was like man I come my parents are
nurses I lived at the Catholic Worker I
used to live in a homeless shelter what
am I doing with this guy and and the
thing was it was like a no attached
commitment to fund the journalism that
we wanted to do and so that was
basically how all of this started and we
went through a whole mess and we made
mistakes and everything but but the
point was that it started a process that
created an ability to have
an autonomous news organization where
Pierre Omidyar who funds this never
tells us what to do what to write what
not to write and and we're you know so
many journalists are fighting over how
do you do this kind of journalism and we
feel very blessed to be in the position
that we're in and and so we started what
is now known as the intercept and we
brought in people like Cora courier who
spoke earlier tonight who was always one
of my favorite young journalists and
Ryan Devereaux who I had worked with on
Blackwater stuff and and dirty wars and
Murtaza Hussein who was an amazing you
know young journalist and and we started
to build something and we did it in a
way where we didn't know exactly where
we were going but we got to the point
and we've gotten to the point now where
we have an incredible editor-in-chief
Betsy Reid who I had worked with for so
long who is an incredible leader she's
she's quiet she's humble but she is an
incredible editor and has amazing
insight into the kind of news that is
not being done anywhere else and and and
we have this freedom to to work on the
stories that were pursuing without
regard to any hurdles that are thrown in
our direction and we have great lawyers
working for us and and and others but
before I talk about the content of what
we're here tonight about which is the
assassination complex I want to say one
thing we are incredibly grateful to the
individual who risked Liberty freedom
and their life to leak these documents
to us this is
we are living in a moment when a man who
is in the White House right now is a
constitutional lawyer by trade and
training who won the Nobel Peace Prize
who was portrayed as a transformative
figure in American politics and is
presiding over a global assassination
program is presiding over the the most
intense presiding over the most intense
persecution and prosecution of
whistleblowers in US history
has used the Espionage Act more during
his two terms in office than any than
all of the presidencies in US history
combined since that Act was signed into
law in the early 1900s this President
Obama is viewed as as this great liberal
leader who had incredible support and
yet Dick Cheney I imagine him
fly-fishing somewhere in Wyoming having
a good chuckle over how great this
period has been for their agenda for the
agenda that John McCain would have never
been able to implement for the agenda
that Mitt Romney would have never been
able to implement Barack Obama has used
his credibility has used his credibility
as a popular Democrat in a can a
constitutional lawyer to to seek to
legitimize what amounts to a global
assassination program you know that that
that every president since Gerald Ford
has has upheld an executive order that
says that the United States does not
assassinate people and yet the US
Congress has not only avoided
legislating that issue or defining the
term assassination but has actively
refused to do so and the reason is
because if Congress actually defined
assassination if Congress actually said
okay that's an executive order and we're
now going to translate that into law it
would mean that you would have five
hundred
Plus lawmakers who would be also
responsible for this policy so instead
of assassination what we're told is that
we're engaged in targeted killing we're
engaged in a high-value targeting
campaign no no no what we are engaged in
is a global hit squad program where we
are we are the embodiment of what
Richard Clark who was the
counterterrorism czar under Clinton and
then and then came over into the bush
era he told Congress in a secret hearing
shortly after 9/11 that the reason that
Clinton didn't want to do all of the
kinds of things that we're seeing right
now is they didn't want to give the
perception of running an Israeli style
assassination program you you
fast-forward to the present time and we
have a popular Liberal Democratic
president who has basically said that it
is legitimate for the United States to
have a parallel judicial system whereby
people are sentenced to death by a
committee that meets on Terror Tuesday
and puts people's terrorist statistics
on what they call baseball cards and it
goes up to kill this chain of command
and at the top of that is the President
of the United States who acts in the
spirit of an emperor and decides who
will live and die on any given day
because he says so I want to know with
all the Liberals who have supported this
policy and at one point it was 70% of
self-described liberals said that they
supported drone strikes abroad I want to
know how many of those people when when
they hear the phrase President Donald
Trump's kill list are going to still
believe in that principle because I'll
tell you something there's no such thing
as a democratic or republican cruise
missile there's no such thing as a
democratic or republican drone strike
every nation in the world has a right to
defend itself that that isn't that is
not a question and by nation I would
also include Native Americans in the
United States but every nation in the
world has a right to defend itself what
we are engaged in right now and I say we
because if you pay taxes you are a
supporter of this we are engaged not in
defensive war we're engaged in
pre-emptive warfare which was the Cheney
doctrine and and and what President
Obama has done which will endure for
generations to come is he has made it
possible for whoever the next president
is hawkish Hillary Clinton the cruise
missile liberal or nutty as a fruitcake
Donald Trump who believes that Muslims
shouldn't even be allowed to visit this
country as as tourists whichever one of
those two people ends up winning that
election is going to be continuing these
policies and Bernie Sanders by the way
and I'm sure there are people that are
feeling the Bern in this room tonight
and there's a and there's and there's a
lot of there's and and there's a lot of
things that Bernie Sanders says that I
think are really worth supporting and
it's unusual to hear the kinds of things
on a national stage that he is saying
but but the reality about Bernie Sanders
is that when the when the groundwork was
being laid for the future invasion of
Iraq in the 1990s Bernie Sanders
supported legislation in 1998 called the
Iraq liberation act which made regime
change in Iraq the law of the land he
endorsed a bill supported it both
publicly and with his signature that was
drafted by Donald Rumsfeld
who was not yet the defense secretary
William Kristol the notorious infamous
neocon Paul Wolfowitz and others who
brought you the invasion of Iraq Bernie
Sanders supported the legislation that
they drafted in the in an early stage in
the form of a letter to President
Clinton that then laid the groundwork
for the invasion of Iraq Bernie Sanders
then supported the most
merciless regime of economic sanctions
in modern history against the Iraqi
people in an attempt to starve them into
overthrowing the government of Saddam
Hussein it did not affect Saddam's
regime instead it killed hundreds of
thousands of Iraqis Bernie Sanders
rightly blasts Hillary Clinton for being
a regime change fan and she is she is as
hawkish as they come he blasts Hillary
Clinton for her alliance with Henry
Kissinger and she should be blasted for
that but but the fact is that we are not
as journalists Democrats or Republicans
we have an obligation to hold anyone in
power or seeking power accountable and
if you think Bernie Sanders sheets are
clean they're not
[Applause]
we Bernie Sanders was asked by Chris
Hayes of MSNBC at the most recent
Democratic Town Hall directly if he
supports the kill list and Bernie
Sanders said as it's currently being
administered yes I do support it now as
it's currently being administered is
laid out in this book and this book by
the way that that we produce is a
complete team effort of everyone all of
these investigative journalists that
work with it with us on this book that
did the reporting on it we pour it over
these documents and tried to present to
people a counter-narrative based on the
government's own documents of what is
happening around the world what these
documents show is that the Obama
administration is relying on a system
that depends on a mathematical formula
for determining how many civilians are
killed in these drone strikes that
basically is guaranteed to almost always
result in the numbers zero so Obama is
set to release their statistics on the
number of people killed outside of
declared war zones of Iraq and
Afghanistan and they're gonna say that a
minimal number of people have been
killed but what they're not going to
tell you is that in many cases they
declare that anyone killed in drone
strikes is an enemy killed in action
eki a until or unless posthumously
proven to have not been so it's sort of
turning the idea of due process in a
very gruesome lethal way on its head
this kind of reporting that that we are
doing at the intercept is the result of
an incredible team effort of fact
checkers and lawyers and and we have an
incredible design team of people who try
to visualize the data so that it can be
shared and digested and understood but I
also I there's one person that I want to
point out in particular and that is my
amazing colleague Roger Hodge who was
the former editor-in-chief of Harper's
Magazine
Roger edited this book and he he did it
on his own time in addition to being
full time
at the intercepts so I just want to
thank Roger Hodge for all the work that
he did on this
and the final thing I want to say is
that we are living in a time and in a
moment when there is a war against
independent journalism there is a war
against independent journalism in the
form of the targeting of whistleblowers
there is a war against independent
journalism in the targeting of
journalists phone records and
surveilling their communications this
administration which claimed to be
ushering in the era of the most
transparent administration in US history
has sent a message to those in
government who want to blow the whistle
on government misconduct
unconstitutional activity extrajudicial
killing that we will pursue you to the
end of the earth and and what that means
is that when things like the killing of
Osama bin Laden happen John Brennan can
leak like a sieve and tell everyone lies
about a wife being put in front of bin
Laden and a shootout happening and all
of the other stuff that they said those
are official leaks those are acceptable
when David Petraeus wants to leak or
share classified information to make
himself look like Superman in front of
his mistress that's acceptable Hillary
Clinton's emails that would be an utter
scandal if it was a private citizen who
was doing that because of reasons of
conscience some government contractor
who said well I want I want to have
classified II met material sent to my
personal email address those people
would be get going down on espionage
charges right now instead she may be the
next president of the United States the
the fact is that we live in a society
where so many people that are at the
bottom of the chain of command are the
ones standing up Chelsea Manning was
sentenced to 30 years in a military
prison because she blew the whistle on
war crimes you just watched one thing
and that was the Collateral Murder video
where where Iraqis civilians and Reuters
journalists were gunned down - applause
and laughter by members of the United
States
military the idea that Chelsea Manning
is serving 30 years in prison for
exposing that and other misdeeds and
illegal activity by the US government
and David Petraeus is a professor
somewhere and William and Krystal is a
William McRaven is a professor somewhere
he's the head of the entire University
of Texas educational system right now a
former commander of JSOC who tried to
give sheep to Afghan villagers to
apologize for killing their loved ones
and digging bullets out of the bodies of
pregnant women the idea that we live in
a society where it's up to the young
people the lower command people to blow
the whistle and those in power cover it
up or share classified information
because they want to sleep with someone
that's a sick commentary on our society
I'm gonna end the chat part of this
evening by saying this what what we're
trying to do at the intercept is flawed
and we're open to criticism and we
listen to people who weigh in and have
something critical to say about us we we
are not arrogant about what we're doing
we are trying to build something
different we're seeking different ways
to fund journalism I've been at the
other end of this where you spend three
months of your year begging for funding
begging for finance trying to convince
people that what you're doing is is is
worth something and and and and we're
not we're not perfect but what we're
trying to do is to create an independent
media organization that people when they
come to our site or they come to our
work they know where we're coming from
the notion of objectivity is total
[ __ ] the New York Times is not
objective the New York Times is an
advocacy publication CNN is not
objective it is an advocacy network it's
an advocate for the way things are in
the view of the state we don't want to
go to the White House Correspondents
Association dinner we want to dwell with
people like you we want to dwell with
people who live on the other end of the
barrel of the gun and and and I add the
last thing I'll say is this I want to
dedicate this entire evening and I hope
all of you keep this in your hearts and
minds when you leave here today to all
of those whistleblowers known and
unknown who risk life and liberty to
tell us stories that we wouldn't hear
otherwise those are the true heroes in
our society thank you very much
[Applause]